[Musique]
momone factory mais à pied 40
travailleurs à montréal en plus
d'annoncer une baisse de salaire de 10%
chez les ch ce gestionnaire
eric fourni et associés et producteur
exécutif de moment factory bonsoir
bonsoir décision votre entreprise est
quand même reconnu mondialement pour ses
créations il merci comme on vient de
voir puis les gens qui sont dans le coin
de montréal voit l'éclairage du pont
jacques-cartier notamment le soir c'est
chez vous ça pourquoi vous devez faire
des compressions aujourd'hui c'est quand
même 10 % de votre personnel
oui bien évidemment la crise du coc vide
aussi frappé chez nous mois de mars sont
d'aider pris la décision de garder tout
le monde de mettre tout le monde en
télétravail alors on a vraiment passé à
travers les six derniers mois
l'optimisme est enthousiaste que il y
aurait le rebond cet automne et que
finalement le carnet de commandes d
extrêmement sain qu'on a des ailes et se
renouveler de façon naturelle cet
automne de sorte qu'on pourrait garder
tout le monde
mais pourquoi le carnet de commandes ne
se renouvelle pas pourquoi ça vous
touche vous mais fondamentalement
l'entreprise et diversifié
géographiquement dans tous les marchés
on signe des projets à long terme nos
projets sont de l'ordre de 12 à 24 mois
et est en général évidemment les nos
clients sont des entreprises des clients
dans le monde du divertissement dans
différents domaines et les incertitudes
actuelles font que les contrôles ne se
concrétise par les gens attendre mieux
comprendre de la reprise le rebond
surtout que des noirs est-ce que donc
votre chiffre d'affaires a chuté
oui à une baisse dans le fond la literie
conçu de toujours nous ce carnet de
commandes s'est incarné commandes on
doit toujours se renouveler
il est en baisse de combien pensez y
dorment des chiffes de 30 % généralement
comme les industries souffert des siens
montréal je dirais que notre notre défi
méritait vraiment de
mais d un carnet de commandes donc on a
pu accélérer certains projets mais
fondamentalement c'est l'offre de
transport et les soutiens
gouvernementaux ne sont plus suffisants
pour vous subvention salariale par
exemple malgré les subventions
salariales du fédéral ont été
extrêmement important pour nous durant
la période
combien de vies pour les prochains mois
mais malheureusement évidemment comme le
gouvernement a annoncé déjà qu' il y
aurait plus souvent sur l'eau nous il
faut prendre des décisions pour le moyen
terme est-ce que vos projets est-ce que
plusieurs de vos projets que vous
développiez avant la cave et 19 sont sur
la glace et est est ce que l'ensemble de
vos projets finalement sont sur la glace
non non non on parle pour le ghana
nantissement on ne me c'est 10 % des
gens qui ont quitté mauvaise facture
aujourd'hui il s'est encore 90% des gens
qui sont chez nous pour travailler sur
des projets alors violent des projets
quintinie sur la glace si les projets
quand il se repose
alors c'est vraiment une combinaison de
tout ayant un projet qui beaucoup de
gens ont remarqué au cours de l'été une
association avec le ciné parc orford
donc avec avec une expérience encore une
fois immersive
est-ce que vous tire un bon bilan de ça
et que vous voulez poursuivre ce type
d'expérience mais ça faisait partie des
choses qu'on voulait faire cet été et
durant de coved évidemment comme il y
avait un certain relâchement de la la
cadence des projets on a mis beaucoup
d'initiatives en classe pour essayer de
nouvelles idées et ce le plus le dren le
code génétique de l'entreprise on essaie
des choses que après on voit les
réactions du public et la réaction des
clients potentiels
alors oui ça crée de l'intérêt des riens
qui s'est concrétisée depuis pour autant
demander on sait pas si l'été prochain
ça va revenir
ben onu on a eu des demandes d'un peu
partout dans le monde alors là on est en
train de faire un post mortem voir un
peu les résultats et dans le fond voire
un peu quels sont les balises qui
permettrait de renouveler cette cette
proposition comment vous
pensez à votre relance et comment vous
pensez aussi participer à la relance
économique
la gueule c'était de niveau évidemment
ce qu'on a fait c'est con on a quand
même une très bonne diversification de
marchés donc nous nous nos antennes un
peu partout dans le monde nous bureau en
désign bureaux en europe nos bureaux aux
états-unis nous aide à mieux saisir
aussi ce sont les marchés les clients
qui pourrait revenir plus rapidement
donc on a une vraie base d'intelligence
de marché qui nous permet de comprendre
un peu ce qui se passe économiquement
puis au niveau du divertissement dans
ces marchés dans la deuxième chose c'est
évidemment toute cette période de covile
permet aussi de rondes et discussions un
peu plus stratégiques avec des
partenaires vont essayer de voir des
nouvelles solutions d'affaires des
nouveaux formats qui vont faire que le
pot scolytes volet différence avec des
nouvelles plateformes de divertissement
on pense aussi que les centres villes
ont besoin d'animation on pense que dans
un monde de distanciation toutes nos
activités extérieures comme l'illuminant
comme les activités de martin sur des
sites patrimoniaux sont des projets qui
pourraient être extrêmement intéressant
pour des villes pour des destinations
touristiques
donc vous avez confiance en l'avenir
craignez-vous une deuxième vague cela
dit est ce que ça pourrait mettre en
péril l'avenir de moment factory londres
au nom de l'avenir de moment factory
n'est pas parce que je pense que c'est
beaucoup ce n'est justement courtes
heures on était sur une courbe de
croissance accélérée depuis plusieurs
années et là évidemment c'est un
ralentissement ne sais pas c'est pas une
remise en question d'entreprises sont
évidents très simple parfait merci bonne
chance merci monsieur fournier
merci monsieur clients mois